dot org
washington journal continues
joining us from pittsburgh at the
carnegie mellon university is alan
meltzer a professor there an expert on
the federal reserve and its role written
three books on the federal reserve mr
meltzer the front page story of the new
york times this morning is if fed missed
bubble how will it see a new one it
writes that uh the fact that mr bernanke
and other regulators still have not
explained why they failed to recognize
the last bubble is the weakest link in
the fed's push for more power it raises
the question why should congress or
anyone else have faith that future fed
officials will recognize the next bubble
before you answer that question was the
federal reserve set up in the first
place to recognize bubbles in our
economy not at all it was set up
back in 1913 by
president woodrow wilson to
make under the gold standard so there
weren't very many possibilities of
bubbles and they couldn't do much about
them anyway it was a very passive
institution when it was set up and it
was set up on a program that president
wilson did the the big argument was not
whether we were going to have a federal
reserve the question was then and many
times later
who was going to control it whether it
was going to be controlled by what were
called the politicians in washington or
the bankers in the country and wilson's
compromise was to make semi-autonomous
regional banks 12 of them and uh and a
board in washington that would supervise
them
explain how the federal reserve works
well nowadays it's it's very different
it's a very different organization from
the one that wilson helped to get
started uh
what it does is it tries to control
a single interest rate called the
federal funds rate the rate at which
bankers sell
reserves
supplied by the federal reserve sell
back and forth to each other to cover
something called required reserves banks
have to hold reserves with the federal
reserve and
they
if they have too many they want to sell
them if they have too few they have to
they want to buy them and so there's a
market for those reserves and the
federal reserve controls the rate in
that market and by doing that
it influences
many other rates including the stock
exchange and the mortgage rate and so on
but not directly
it has also been dubbed the lender of
last resort where did that phrase come
from and how does it work oh that's
historically an old old phrase certainly
goes back to the 19th century bank of
england the idea was that when there was
a crisis the uh there had to be somebody
well a crisis like the one that we just
went through when none of the banks want
to lend to each other they don't trust
each other they want to hold cash
they're not sure what's going to happen
tomorrow or the day the day after
tomorrow so the best thing to do for
them is to hold cash there was somebody
that was supposed to supply that cash
that was the lender of last resort and
that job became the job of the of the
central bank the federal reserve in our
system
in most countries at the time that this
started the central banks were all
private institutions later many of them
became public institutions
you talked about how the the fed was set
up to be independent
what does it mean to be independent and
how is that how is that independence
viewed within the federal reserve
well
the idea of independence began under the
gold standard so there were real
restrictions on what they could do
but they were independent the main idea
of independence at that time was that
the federal reserve would not finance
the government that if the government
had to borrow it had to borrow and pay
the market interest rate and the central
bank wouldn't finance them because
everyone knew then
as they sometimes forget now that when
they finance the government and that by
by buying its paper they are really
creating the possibility of inflation or
if they fail to do it the possibility of
deflation
so independence originally meant
that they were control constrained under
the gold standard not to buy government
debt the idea of independence has
changed many many times most federal
reserve
governors that is most federal reserve
chairman have not been terribly
independent paul volcker was the most
independent chairman that the federal
reserve has had and he that's why he was
able a main reason why he was able to
end the big inflation of the 1970s the
present federal reserve is not acting
independently at all it cooperates with
the treasury and bailing out various
agencies no previous federal reserve
ever did anything like
the things that this one is doing well
how is the word independence viewed
within the federal reserve well
when i was writing my book i asked them
about that we had about a two hour
conversation about it uh
it it's pretty vague i would say in
their mind uh they
they don't like legislate congress
looking too closely at what they do but
of course this is a democratic country
and congress under the constitution has
the right to coin money and regulate the
value thereof so the federal reserve is
their agent
uh they don't like they they often
cooperate with the administration but
they like to keep a hands-off
relationship with the administration so
that they're not forced to do things
that they don't think are in the public
interest
i have here at the desk before me
volume one and or excuse me book one and
two of volume two oh these are advanced
copies these are advanced copies you
wrote a previous um volume uh on the
federal reserve so this is the three
very lengthy books on the federal
reserve uh why
who did you talk to for these for these
books and what sort of access did you
have to documents oh the federal reserve
was very cooperative
they knew me of course for a long time
they knew i was a critic they were very
happy to have someone uh who was as
critical as i was would not be seen as a
an insider writing their history they've
always they've for a long time wanted
the history to be written and
and they were very cooperative they made
available to me under the freedom of
information act
everything that i asked for and the
federal reserve banks are
not under the freedom of information act
but i went to new york and they
cooperated with me very nicely gave me
access to everything that i asked for i
interviewed many of them uh for the book
they were very cooperative
you wrote in you the first volume dates
back to the beginning of the federal
reserve and you wrote in in one of these
books that
the federal reserve has not had has not
been marked by controversy in its
90-year
history there have not been any
significant leaks or ethical scandals
why is that it has a higher spree decor
and it's had from very early days it's
had that esprit de corps and it has a
it just has avoided any of those
scandals it's minor scandals people
leaking information
once in a while but even that has been
a relatively small thing but no one has
stolen
the money to my knowledge it's just been
a very good organization
it's considered to have the best
professional economic staff in the
country if not in the world
well that's part of what the new york
times writes about today in that it
talks about who serves
within the federal reserve and and it
talks about that uh it's an echo chamber
within the federal reserve and that is
why it was difficult for
uh federal reserve ben bernanke when he
served under the formal federal reserve
alan greenspan for them to see the
housing bubble happening
what is your what is your take on that i
don't agree with that
there was a member of the board uh who
has since died who presented them with
that information
alan greenspan himself testified one of
the mystery
of the current crisis or disgraceful
aspects of the current crisis and
perhaps more accurate is that the
congress won't do anything about what
was the initiating cause of the crisis
under various administrations democrat
as well as republican they have tried to
increase
housing and so
after a while they were giving no down
payment loans to people who didn't have
any credit ratings if that isn't an
invitation to difficulty uh i it's hard
to think of what would be and alan
greenspan among other people testified
about that my colleague at the american
enterprise institute peter wallison who
at one time was the chief counsel in the
white house and the former chief counsel
in the treasury therefore a very
knowledgeable person about these has
spoken over and over again about the
dangers that were coming from fannie mae
and freddie mac and how buying these bad
mortgages you know the government owns
half the bad mortgages that were
produced under
under low
bad prime loans under subprime loans
you know we're going to lose hundreds of
billions of dollars
and what does the treasury do it just
expanded the amount that fannie mae and
freddie mac could buy that's a scandal
it's a scandal because what we need to
do is get rid of fannie mae and freddie
mac
if they're going to subsidize housing as
they almost certainly will it should be
on the budget that's the way democratic
governments are supposed to run frannie
may and freddie mac are a run around the
democratic process and open to
corruption and there has been corruption
well professor meltzer this article
notes the
hostility that has
increased toward the federal reserve and
the chairman ben bernanke and so
but before this hostility turned on the
federal reserve when alan greenspan was
heading up the federal reserve there
seemed to be
admiration
or
reverence for what mr greenspan would
say how can this institution be both
revered by some people and have disdain
from others that's easy when times are
good and things are going well they look
great and people like them when times
are bad as they have been
people say look why why is the public
angry about what the federal reserve is
doing they don't like the bailouts they
don't like the fact that they are
advancing money for example to the
general motors acceptance corporation
called gmac
they
don't like the idea that we've advanced
money to general motors and chrysler
they don't like the idea that they've
expense billions of dollars tens
hundreds of billions of dollars to
america aig
and they say why are they giving all
this money to the bankers and the people
that made the problem and nothing to us
well mr professor meltzer there seems to
be distrust of of the federal reserve so
can you explain
how the board is set up who serves on
the board and how these regional banks
are set up some view this institution as
a secret society
well hardly
it's
a lot more transparent than it used to
be
in the history of central banking
and up to certainly in the 1930s maybe
even to the 1950s
it was none of your business what the
central bank did and they more or less
said that you know they operated
and did what they wanted to do and if
you didn't like it that was a problem
that you had
we're a democratic country so more and
more there's been an increase in
transparency the federal reserve
announces since 1994 it finally got
around to announcing what its policy
action was it releases its minutes as
i've said they've made available to me
everything that they want congress is
pushing to get
the
to get more information from them all
the time the chairman of the federal
reserve testifies in congress four times
a year he talks about what his plans are
and what he how he sees the world and
what he thinks the problems are so
they're just much more transparent than
they ever were and more so than most
many central banks are
so it's just not true that it's a secret
society okay so how does the board work
and uh why are there regional banks
well the regional banks were there as as
i said earlier because of the compromise
i mean who was going to run this
important institution and president
wilson developed a compromise which said
they were going to be
semi-autonomous
whatever that meant at the time
semi-autonomous regional banks for eight
to twelve in the end there were twelve
and they were going to do the action for
and
make the
major decisions and a board in
washington that would supervise them
gradually that power shifted so that the
board in washington has most of the
control over what gets done but there
are 12 regional banks and
now not originally but now
there are
there is a major entity in the federal
reserve is called the federal open
market committee
that meets
regularly in washington eight times a
year
and they make the decisions about what
the interest rate is going to be various
other things that the fed is responsible
for
that committee is made up of the
seven members of the board of governors
the washington part and five
representatives of the central banks one
of whom new york is always there and the
others four
rotate through the 12 banks through the
other 11 banks
so that's the organization 12 people
there are 19 members who come to the
open market committee
the 12 bankers but only five of those
bankers get to vote
as we go to the first phone call for
professor milter let's put on the screen
the the federal open market committee
definition something that mr meltzer was
just talking about for our viewers to
read dalton georgia danny on the
republican line good morning
hello
thank you for c-span it's good to have
open lines and be able to talk and
appreciate what you said about the gold
standard and
enjoy watching this gentleman on tv very
learning but i do have one question
uh you know especially about volcker
back in the 80s
what was it he was doing
you know i know he put a stop to
inflation but he what he had to do
he made money tight and raised the
interest rate so high that we had a two
year recession uh 10 11 unemployment and
reagan came in so people paid the price
for that that hurt the manufacturing
sector because the dollar got so uh
expensive uh relative to other
currencies and now
uh that i think that really was what
started the bubble because between then
and now the amount of money for profit
the earnings every year the financial
sector has gone from 20 cents on every a
dollar earned in america to 42 cents and
how are you going to have labor intense
uh
industries and how are you going to have
people working when all the money is
flowing to the financial sector where
you don't have to hire that many people
and they're arrogating themselves all
this money bonuses and everything else
and nobody can stop it last thing don't
you think it's time to bust down break
up those big monopolies also
oligopolistic places like goldman sachs
and and just do regional banking let
banking get back down to what's supposed
to be and that's loaning money to people
to earn to earn money in their own
businesses and also to have a home for
their families that's what banking
should be about not speculation not
about hedges and not about anything else
mr meltzer well there are a lot of
questions there so let me start with a
few of them first
yes it's true that volcker raised
interest rates that's the way we ended
the inflation so it's it's also true
that the unemployment rate went as high
as 10.8 percent at that point a little
bit
higher than it is
than it was at the peak so far this time
uh but it's also true that the
common
didn't recognize that following the end
of that inflation we had probably
almost 20 years of
stable growth and low inflation with
very mild recessions so when ronald
reagan
took office in 1980 the stock market was
around 800. when he left office in
1989 it was up around 3 000 so that was
a period of great prosperity and that
prosperity went on until the federal
reserve made the big mistake of keeping
money too easy and more importantly the
government made the mistake of
continuing a bad housing policy if you
have loans to people who can't pay
you're going to have defaults and that's
what we did and that's a housing policy
and the blame for that belongs in the
congress and in successive
administrations neither republican nor
democrats were good enough to stop that
now as to the problem of what the banks
should do i am in favor have testified
in both the house and the senate that
what we do need to do is get rid of
something called too big to fail the the
idea that the federal reserve bails out
the large banks and lets the small banks
fail and so my proposal is a very simple
one and it says
the bank can choose how big it wants to
be
but the larger it is
the more
proportionally more it has to hold
reserves it has to have its stockholders
at risk not the public the present
system is a system in which
the large banks take the get the profits
and the public takes the losses as it's
now doing that's not a system that's
either good for the country and it's
certainly not good for the taxpayers so
we need to get rid of that and we need
to have people tell their congressman we
want to be rid of too big to fail and
too big to fail
davey florida john on our democrats on
good morning
good morning
yes professor um to your last point
there um
why did the federal rules i have two
questions too please indulge me i have
two questions why did the federal
reserve
let investment banking go under the
federal reserve radar it should have
been regulated like a bank they should
have let all the sheltering going on and
the palandering and everything else that
those investment bankers um engaged in
why did the federal reserve let that
slip around also my second question
does not the federal reserve have a
schizophrenic characteristic to it i say
that because
the federal reserve receives a statutory
authority through congress
yet it's appointed by the executive
branch
how can something be self-autonomous
when there is a dichotomy of authority
and um
and approval would it not be better that
we make that a fourth
leg of government and make that a voting
position the federal reserve chairman
should be voted just like any other
elected official and be held accountable
for what he does
professor i believe in accountability
let me say
that let's first get the facts
the the chairman and the members of the
board of governors are appointed by the
president and confirmed by the
senate just the same as the secretary of
the treasury the secretary of defense
the secretary of state so there's no
difference there between that and any
other major function of government
the members of the banks
the federal reserve banks the 12 federal
reserve banks are appointed by the
boards of directors of the banks and
approved by the board in washington but
not by the congress and that's a
contentious issue it's been a
contentious issue for many years and
people have different views about that i
don't see anything wrong with that
system
with the way that has worked as a matter
of fact i think the presidents bring
information to the board meetings that
is not available in washington they
bring a lot of information that they
learn from their
local people the people on their boards
the businessmen labor unions
general public in their areas and that's
valuable information that should be
present and is useful to them now as to
the question about the investment banks
yes i mean
we have this schizophrenic attitude that
what we need is more regulation but
regulation fails the reason regulation
just think what we've been through
recently we had made off it was a
regulated by the securities and exchange
commission we had stanford regulated by
the securities and exchange commission
we had the
we had the big banks in new york
one of the things that people don't hear
very much is that the federal reserve
had people sitting in every one of those
banks during the period in which they
were making these bad loans and they
were not doing anything about it so the
idea that regulation is going to get us
out of this problem is wrong what we
need to do is go to put the incentives
on the bankers
and that's what i want to do make the
bankers responsible for the loans make
every banker get up in the morning and
worry about what's on his balance sheet
how can we do that the answer is get rid
of too big to fail don't bail them out
if they fail they fail and their
stockholders take the money now what
does failure mean failure doesn't mean
that the bank disappears it just means
that we wipe out the stockholders
and we get rid of the management and we
re-adjust the ownership and control of
those assets to somebody who hopefully
will manage them better and that's what
we need to do and until we do that and
we did that up until 1970 it's only 30
or 35 years that we've been bailing out
banks more and more all the time and
that's a big mistake because it
encourages risk-taking economists call
that moral hazard but it's just a
mistake you take the losses and they
make the profits not a good idea winamac
indiana mark on the independent line
yes
the only solution to this problem is to
end the federal reserve
our framers knew about paper money and
knew about the evils of a central bank
a central bank is the seventh rule in
the communist manifesto
if i can read john adams wrote the
thomas jefferson 1787.
all the prophecies confusions
distressing america
arise not from the defects from the
constitution or confederation
not from
a want of honor virtue
so much as a downright ignorance of the
nature of coin credit and circulation
it gives back to revolutionary periods
very similar to what we have now
we did issue paper money back then
the continental currency wasn't backed
by gold just like now we're in the fiat
money system
and what happened to that continental
currency was it crashed
and that's what's going to happen now mr
meltzer
well
i agree with you that we're going to
have we're
very likely to have an inflation again
but i don't think we want to go back to
the gold standard i know that's going to
irritate a lot of people who are friends
of the gold standard including my old
friend congressman paul but the fact is
there's the gold standard can only work
if other countries joined the gold
standard otherwise the united states on
the gold standard would buffer every
single currency shock in the world
i don't think we want to do that second
for years when people talked about the
gold standard i would say on the lecture
platform the lecture platform we don't
have the gold standard because it isn't
because we don't know about the gold
standard it's because we do what did
that mean it meant that you have to be
willing to accept a lot of unemployment
in order to maintain the gold price
we're not willing to do that the reason
we don't have the gold standard is
because the gold standard required us to
accept a level of unemployment that the
public is not willing to accept
so they went to something
that they hoped would be better
it may not be better
but it's something that they
have no so no sign of wanting to get rid
of
president reagan under pressure
from the gold standard group
had a commission
commission looked into the gold standard
and decided it was not a good idea for
the united states and i think that was
the right decision now we do need
restrictions
we need restrictions on what the federal
reserve can do but those restrictions
should be some that fit with the modern
view that it's both unemployment
and inflation that we have to worry
about and so we need restrictions that
do that and i believe
that there are proposals to do that the
problem in many countries have adopted
proposals of that kind
we have not chosen to do that because of
our congress
next phone call will county illinois
phillip on the republican line
yeah the person who just
called in and spoke to you was
mentioning the gold standard
in the constitution article 1 section 10
no states shall
make anything but gold and silver coin
is tender and payment of debts
and you just kind of explain why this
has been overlooked
i don't see anything a bit amendment the
constitution that has
said this is null and void
but anyway
the
the constitution says
an article 1 section 8 i believe
it says congress shall make laws
regulating the value of coinage
and
that's the article under which the
federal reserve is
created they delegated to the federal
reserve their responsibility at the time
under the gold standard but
no one in the world
wants to go on the gold standard and as
i've said we don't have the gold
standard because we know about the gold
standard and we're not willing to accept
as a modern society the level of
unemployment that that would require
fairmont west virginia george on our
line for democrats good morning yes good
morning uh
i like to question this uh
why does the the federal government have
to bail out all the photo industries and
the banks and all that everything i
think that's wrong we shouldn't have to
bail out anybody amen you do things
wrong and you waste money and you waste
don't do things right you shouldn't be
bailed out you should suffer the
consequences
and i agree with you
and my second goal is
why
does the president of the united states
need all these new czars we have people
department heads and all that were
appointed and and voted on by the senate
and everybody why do we need all these
other czars that he put in place and all
this here big bankroll 80 100 some
thousand dollars a piece we don't need
these bars we have department heads
this is something he's starting out and
it shouldn't be the american people
should be in an uprise and demand that
they'd be removed okay on the
independent line
let me just answer that by saying that
for a very long time
so often that the new york times
eventually used it as the key to their
crossword puzzle i have said capitalism
without failure is like religion without
sin it doesn't work so i agree
wholeheartedly with you and i agree
about the czars we don't need czars this
is a democratic country we elect a
congress we aren't an administration
subject to the public's re review and
that should run our government johnston
colorado dick on the independent line
yes
go ahead
yes uh i was wondering if they
reinstated the glass-steagall act would
this uh limit would this have eliminated
the problem
that we had with the housing no
the housing had to do with
policies to encourage housing
uh policies designed to give
poor people a chance to own their own
homes
that's
on paper a desirable thing but to do it
without down payments and without credit
recognition of their credit losses
that's not a good thing now the
glass-steagall repeal
by the time glass-steagall was repealed
it had almost
no effect if any
the reason was the investment banks were
doing everything that the commercial
banks were doing
and the commercial banks were doing just
about everything that the investment
banks were doing so no other country
adopted glass-steagall and the whole
idea of glass-steagall as a way of
protecting the public is faulty
what we need to do is put the risk on
the people who
who take them make them bear the risk if
we don't do that
there's no regulation that's going to
work i mean the idea that we're going to
appoint some group and we're going to
tell them as the present legislation
says to look for systemic risks what's a
systemic risk nobody can define a
systemic risk you know to the
congressman in your district who says
the company here failed and we're on and
about a thousand people are going to be
unemployed that's a big risk and his job
is to see that something is done about
it and that's going to be just an open
invitation to more of the bailouts that
we have we don't want to go down that
route because that's going to be the
enemy of growth
and freedom youngstown ohio jeff on the
republican line
hello good morning
uh i have a
a a question
it's pretty simple the way i see it
is
the treasury prints the money
the the treasury lends the money to the
banks the banks lend the money to us the
people we pay the banks back their
interest they make their money the banks
pay the u.s treasury back with interest
the treasury makes money us the people
make money we wouldn't have no national
debt and we eliminate the middleman
which is the federal reserve
it's
it caught it's almost like common sense
in business why can't that be done
well we're a big
the largest economy in the world you
know you can read all these things about
china being a threat to us but the
chinese have a
cap of gdp
that's about uh
one-tenth of ours i mean
they may eventually grow but we're a big
country involved in the world we have
exchange rates we have to control
inflation there has to be somebody who
monitors the inflation moving the the
regulation from one place to another is
not going to make very much difference
what we need to do is put on rules which
restrict the independent action that
they can take
and make the people who take the losses
as i've said several times make them
responsible for taking the losses then
we'll have a sound financial system
mr meltzer what is monetary policy
monetary policy is the decision to
control interest rates and money growth
how does it work
the federal reserve
at its meeting the open market committee
decides to set an interest rate and at
that interest rate it's willing to lend
as much as the market wants if the
market wants too much then it's supposed
to raise the interest rate to cut back
on the growth of money
and what is the interest what is
inflation deflation and why should
people care about it
well inflation is a self as a stealth
tax on the wealth that you own that's
fixed in
dollars for example if you own bonds or
if you have a mortgage
then the value of that mortgage the real
value of that mortgage adjusted for
inflation is the amount after we
subtract the inflation so if the
interest rate is
three percent now and the inflation rate
is two percent then the real interest
rate is one percent that's what
is moving around in our system and
causing prosperity or
the lack of prosperity now
what monetary policy does is to set that
interest rate and take the consequences
among the consequences are
inflation unemployment and exchange
rates
next phone call clifton park new york
carl good morning
good morning
um i i have concerns that uh former
executives of
many of the investment banks
especially goldman sachs are and have
been responsible for monetary policy and
for regulation you mean they've been
appointed they've been appointed
and i wonder if you share that concern
and secondly
aren't there uh expert economists in the
various
think tanks and universities that
could be appointed also and may
have more of a
uh
well they are towards the public as far
and the average person as far as those
policies and regulations are concerned
well mr bernanke was a
princeton professor uh there are many
economists i think over the
up until 1965
there were practically there were very
few economists
in the federal reserve system in
particular in principle roles uh now
they're dominated by economists many of
them university economists who become
presidents of the reserve banks
or members of the board of governors
the white house has lawrence summers a
former secretary of the treasury but
also a former harvard professor and
president of harvard university so there
are lots of economists there the problem
is not
is not
the
presence only of people from wall street
but of course
you know if you appoint a secretary of
the treasury from wall street
some of them are going to have
a friendly relationship with the people
that they used to work with and or the
people that used to work with them and
that's inevitable i mean we're not going
to evolve avoid all conflicts of
interest no matter how we how we try
what we need to do as i keep saying is
we need to put rules on that restrict
them
and my proposal is a very simple one
they should negotiate a rule how much
inflation there's going to be two years
from now they think given their policy
how much unemployment
they negotiate that with the secretary
of the treasury if they achieve it
then that's fine they don't achieve it
they should offer their resignation and
their explanation they're going to be
valid explanations the oil price went up
so the inflation rate looked to be
higher the farm prices went down because
there was a drought i mean
there are lots of things that can happen
over which they have very little control
now i proposed that a long time ago
back in 1988 i was in new zealand i
proposed it to the central bank of new
zealand they adopted it and improved
upon it and that's how we got the idea
of inflation targeting they negotiate
with the minister of finance
comparable to the secretary of the
treasury they negotiate an agreement as
to what the inflation rate will be
what the unemployment rate will be and
if they make it that's fine if they
don't they have to offer their
resignation and their explanation that
idea has spread to many other countries
but not here
next phone call greg in new york on the
independent line
yes good morning alan uh good morning
greta how are you good morning good
morning
uh yeah when i have two things uh let's
take them one at a time uh when i heard
that the problem could be 600 trillion
dollars worth of this bad paper
uh my gut feeling tells me the system is
probably broken uh what do you think
about that and i'll wait for and i'll
give you my second question the fed has
over one
trillion dollars worth of excess
reserves
how much more is that than usual well
it's about a trillion dollars more than
usual
so we have to mop that up or we're going
to have a big inflation now they talk
all the time about how they're going to
do it but they haven't said
that they think it's going to work and i
don't believe it's going to work they
say we're going to pay interest on
reserves and we'll get the banks to hold
them i just don't believe that will work
the way it will sure they'll hold some
more because they receive interest but
they're not going to hold a trillion
dollars worth of excess reserves so when
loan demand starts to pick up they have
to start mopping up those excess
reserves and that's going to be a hard
decision for them to make because it's
going to raise interest rates in the
country and there'll be an outcry from
congress from the administration from
the business community and the labor
unions and probably from the public
which says hey we've got a lot of
unemployment you better do something
about that and let the inflation wait so
that's a problem the federal reserve is
going to have but even more it's a
problem we're all going to have
greg your follow-up yes uh
the the north koreans uh yes the north
koreans the iranians and the russians
and i imagine every other country in the
world is counterfeiting our currency how
big of a problem is it and how much
damage has it done to our money the
bigger far bigger problem is what we're
doing to our money we have
budget deficits
higher than anything that we ever
imagined in a peacetime or even in a
wartime situation you know we have a
president who talks about the fact that
he doesn't like deficits he has to do
something about them but what he mainly
has been doing is increasing them we're
not going to cut the budget deficit
without doing something about health
care but we just increased the amount of
money that we're going to spend on
health care despite what the congress
says so you know
figure this we just said we're going to
put 31 more million more people
onto the medicare rolls
without increasing the number of doctors
does that work
no
how does the congress respond to that
they say well we're going to cut doctors
pay by 21
is that going to get us more doctors and
more medical care of course not
so
they say we're going to cut 500 billion
out of medicare
really with the number of old people
growing
don't believe it
washington dc uh antoine joins us on the
republican line good morning
hi good morning and thanks for c-span
um i had two quick questions
one was
i needed more of a an elaboration on
why would employment unemployment be so
high if we were on the gold standard and
my second question is
instead of the bailout um
wouldn't it make more sense to give more
tax credits to people so they could stay
in their homes and meet their mortgage
requirements professor
well
let's talk about the unemployment under
the gold standard first
if you say that your policy is going to
be to keep the price of gold fixed at a
at a certain price like the old 35
dollar price
then that means that whenever the dollar
starts
just
weaken
you have to pump in money and that's
going to make the economy expand but
when the dollar starts to go down you
have to take out money and you have to
deflate
and when you deflate the first effect of
the deflation falls unemployment so the
economy slows down that's the idea of
maintaining
the the
of of
deflating is to make the economy slow
down so the prices will fall eventually
they'll start to rise again and
then but will take unemployment in the
interim
there's just no way in which we can do
this and keep it on an absolutely
level playing field all the time the
best that we've done the federal reserve
is now 90 some odd years old
the best period that it's had
was the period from
1985 approximately to about 2003. we had
low inflation
and rapid growth and
you know the best evidence of that is
that people stopped complaining about
the growth rate we had minor recessions
but not big recessions
we had
the longest
looking back on that what do people
complain about well they complain about
the distribution of income and they say
this and that about the period and they
reject it but that was the best period
for maintaining for macroeconomic
stability problems of
of
education
productivity growth those things
were
problems that created
difficulties in the distribution of
income that people didn't like
now
the other part of the question i'm sorry
you know what mr professor meltzer i
forgot it myself uh we'll move on to
green top missouri roger on the
democratic line good morning
good morning i'm really pleased to have
an opportunity to speak i would like to
when i studied my economics a number of
decades ago
we talked a lot about federal
reserve open market operations and i
hear and read almost nothing about that
except the small almost footnote in the
wall street journal every day could you
discuss do open market operations still
play in this equation and a little bit
about how
they are the main move
thing that the federal reserve does i
mean
they set a zero
to 25 basis point interest rate to keep
that interest rate they have to buy or
sell i mean what they're doing now is
they're buying mortgages those are open
market operations
they use open market operations to buy
mortgages which are highly illiquid and
they're going to have problems selling
them but they now are buying almost 90
percent of the mortgages that come on
the market
so that's where they're using their open
market operations and they're ever been
every bit as important and powerful as
they have ever been professor alan
meltzer thank you very much sir for your
time this morning we appreciate it thank
you
pleasure
that's it for today's washington journal
we'll be back tomorrow morning at 7 a.m
eastern time but now we want to take you
to george washington university where
admiral mike mullen
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff is going to be talking about the
current state and mission of the united
states military
i'm sure there are times in which he
thought to himself i'm not sure i signed
up for this cruise
but he has been